le spectacle est interdit aux enfants de
moins de 14 ans mais tous les soirs il y
a quand même des gens qui arrivent à
l'accueil avec leurs enfants alors voilà
j'ai décidé d'adapter un petit morceau
de spectacle juste pour que les enfants
aussi puissent passer un bon moment donc
j'ai choisi un petit extrait de Winnie
l'Ourson
ça dure pas très très longtemps en
revanche c'est un véritable épisode
David tu peux nous mettre le petit
passage pour les enfants
aujourd'hui nous allons aider notre cher
ami Darby à trouver une queue ou plutôt
trouver une queue dans la forêt
je vous explique qu'est-ce que sont les
images ça me fait bizarre donc en fait
Darwin Barbie tout simplement une petite
fille c'est une copine de Winnie
l'ourson et en fait dans cet épisode
elle explique qu'elle voudrait bien
avoir une queue comme son copain tigrou
le gentil tigre je dois trouver une
queue Winnie
non
voilà donc vraiment rien de enfin bon
même si là quand même bien compte que
les auteurs et c'est quand même de nous
faire passer un message
que ce sont donc quand même bien
finalement les enfants qui agissent les
pédophiles
trouver j'ai une sorte de don pour
trouver les queues
et donc ce vieux d'où Winnie
l'Ourson
donc examiner les queues de tous ses
amis pour en trouver une qui
conviendrait à la petite Barbie
peut-être qu'une queue n'est pas fait
pour être partagé
les enfants à la fin de l'épisode oui ni
l'ourson trouve en fin une solution au
problème de Darby comment te sens-tu
avec la queue de Bourriquet d'Arby
j'ai tellement de Ré à quel point tu me
rends heureuse